now the Seahawks even at 2 and 2 in
their standings coming down to Los
Angeles for a big division game against
the Rams and Bobby Wagner joins me here
on the Richardson show how are you Bobby
so you heard Chris Collinsworth talk
about your running back days back from
your high school days what type of
running back were you Bobby yeah someone
figure it out I've never played running
back guys cool is that right yeah I
played tight end in high school I was a
5/7 idea a57 tight end so and I was
catching the ball oh you were catching
out here yeah I was catching but I still
doing the same thing after I caught it
which was take you to the house yeah
much understood now you are obviously at
the center of this defense how do you
view your role on this defense what is
your role on this yeah I feel like I am
the quarterback of the defense I feel
like I'm in charge of giving it getting
everybody lined up making sure everybody
gets to play make sure everybody's in
the in the right position and just
making sure everything is communicated
across the board now how do you
communicate that to a group of people
who are very prideful men are not very
there are many wallflowers on that
defense I think he's been is been good
to you know have a couple years you know
playing with the same group of guys so
you get to know one another everybody
gets to accept a role you know it's hard
to tell guys sometimes but relatively
speaking it's pretty easy everybody
allows me to kind of take control and
get everybody lined up well do you have
any kids Bobby Germany Trump do I have
one ok so then I'll use the phrase who's
the worst listener then who's the worst
listener the worst listener probably
sure I want it I just want to say sir
because I like to talk stress-buster
well he's he knows what it's like to
have bad listeners around I mean he's
got he got he got a few too so yeah he's
talking about baby proofing when he's
not he's out there on this team
so how do you describe the first four
weeks of the season for your team at two
it
Bobby I think this last this last game I
feel like we we finally showed what we
are capable of playing the other games
we allowed some plays to kind of get
away from us not necessarily saying that
we played bad ball is just you know when
you have two huge plays happen in the
game it kind of overshadows everything
that you probably did well during that
game so you know I think we're hitting
strike around the time because you know
you never want to catch fire in the
beginning and cool off at the head so I
think we have a good group of guys give
a veteran group that kind of knows you
know we have to we want to play real
well heading into the playoffs so
there's been a lot of teams that have
started five and oh six or no or
whatever and then kind of get burnt out
towards the end of the season so you
just want to make sure you you know
you're hot when you're supposed to be
that that said a 2 and 2 record puts you
in a position this weekend of however
you always want to win a division game
on the road but this is a pretty darn
big one Bobby difference between 3 & 2 &
2 & 3 and obviously going 3 & 2 would
put a little bit of water or rain on the
parade that it seems that the LA Rams
are on through the first quarter of the
season how do you view this Sunday's
game yeah definitely want to sit at 3 &
2 versus 2 & 3 so you know we know it's
a divisional game and this opponent that
that plays this historically very very
well we have to come in and you know
focus in and really take care of
business and you know I think it's gonna
be a really good game get to come home
play in front of family so it should be
fun how many how many tickets you
getting I I'm not serious at 15 maybe 15
20
ok and and who's coming who's part of
the Bobby Wagner posse it's uh like I
have nieces nephews my sister brother
dad you know kind of kinda usual suspect
okay very good and in terms of you know
here we are just a couple days before
the game and now you're seeing Jared
golf on film from so far this year and
based on when you saw him on that
Thursday night game last year is this a
different quarterback from what you're
seeing Bobby
um III feel like it's a more confident
quarterback I always felt like when you
watch him you know he can make these
throws and and he does well you know but
I felt like the confidence wasn't
necessarily there but you know I think
through the course of these four games
he's definitely shown that he has
confidence more hand on the offense you
know seems to play a little bit more
under control and it's probably why
they've been so successful so far
what about Gurley he's look he looks
good and seems like he jumps on over
somebody every game so he's definitely
looking looking like yourself again it's
always fun to play against the running
back like that we know they're gonna you
know they're gonna hand it off to him
they're gonna get him out in the passing
game so it's coming a fun matchup let's
be honest though Bobby he only hurdles
those who are making a business decision
this is true though those that go low
[ __ ] or smaller ones but you know I
know he's gonna try it at some point
he's gonna try to hurt a big guy but you
know I think he tries to run people over
too so he's either really good bet when
you say - that means you are you are not
gonna be one of those making a business
decision I'm assuming definitely not I
would definitely be putting my shoulders
to his shoulder here reading set to take
on the Rams on the Rich Eisen show do
you sense a difference any difference in
Pete Carroll on a week where obviously
it's a division game but he goes back to
where he once belonged in the LA
Coliseum do you notice any change for a
week like this in him
no I notice anything everything has been
status quo it's been a spin normally
kind of you know lives by treating every
game the same every game of the
championship game to him and you know
that this week is no is no different
okay and and then in terms of the locker
room and so much conversation in the
offseason non-playing season and then
obviously where the ups and downs in
September of an offense and a defense
that needs to get on the same page
together to win and I asked this of
Warren Moon I asked this also in in the
a couple weeks ago with Doug Baldwin do
you guys need to have some sort of I
guess not discord is not the proper word
but some sort of angst built up in that
locker room in order to channel it
against your opponent in order to be
successful
Bobby what do you mean just angst just
like to its that maybe not everybody's
all on the same page but once you guys
get out there you just roll all or row
in the same direction no I think I think
everybody does get on the same page when
it comes to Sunday because it's uh you
know we know what's online we know what
we're playing for and we know why we're
out there and at the end of the day you
know you're playing for the guy next to
you so you can't let that person down so
I think you know when the lights are on
it's time to play everybody's ready to
go alright and this weekend coming to
Los Angeles as you said coming home and
really maybe as I mentioned raining on
the Rams parade what do you think that
would mean to come out with a win this
Sunday for you and this team I think it
would just be a good divisional win I
think you know we played a really good
division in my opinion and you know the
Rams are you know sitting at tops of the
division I think if we win it will
either tie us or put this right we want
to be so that's that's kind of our goal
we want to make sure we went into
division you know get a couple home
games and then playoff time and this is
kind of one of those steps to to
recharge them to go all right Bobby
we've got a Thursday night game coming
up with the UN in Arizona I look forward
to seeing you there what it's on that I
don't network Cup I look forward to
right back at you
that's Bobby Wagner the Seattle Seahawks
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy